[Musique]
n'y pensez même pas
vous faire perdre la tête
ennjimi
à
je
les accompagne partout les yeux
[Musique]
partout
c
comment va le fruit de nos amours
c'est un menteur texte pas les parents
qui nous sommes et leurs collègues
trois personnes plus ou moins c'est ça
[Musique]
ça me prend pas soin quand je suis seul
homme du bonheur
à l'extrême inverse intrigue
[Musique]
ce
n'est pas pareil malagouen
il lui dit moi que la plupart des gens
c'est les grands sont tous un peu malade
1 j'aurais dû garder les pieds sur terre
pour deux jours à tuer de protéger
davantage
[Musique]
une orange
en sorte que la retiennent tout
[Musique]
quand la
literie
rendez vous de l'histoire
[Musique]